When it comes to climate,
how do we stop preaching to the choir?
What can we do to grab the attention
of those individuals who are disengaged?
I ask these questions
as an artist, as an educator
and as a lifelong resident
of Miami, Florida,
one of the most climate-vulnerable
cities in the United States.
In Miami, we're already
seeing storm drains
that erupt with water
after heavy rainfalls,
and cars and properties that are damaged
due to flooding from high tide.
And we've all seen
the devastation of Hurricane Ian
as it barreled at 150 miles an hour,
bringing 10 feet of storm surge
to the Gulf Coast,
just two and a half hours from my home.
My home sits at six feet above sea level.
But today, we see cranes
populating [the] Miami skyline,
building more and more skyscrapers
at the water’s edge.
Thanks to this brazen overdevelopment,
many Miamians aren't aware of the threat
that sea level rise
poses to their families,
their homes and their communities.
I myself wasn’t aware of just
how dire Miami’s situation was
until I traveled to Antarctica.
I went there in 2006
as part of the National Science Foundation
Antarctic Artists and Writers Program.
I spoke with scientists there
and I learned just how
vulnerable my city was.
I was standing on the very ice
that threatened to melt
and drown the only place
I've ever called home.
So I took that ice and I made art with it.
I took ice that glaciologists
brought back from their field stations
and melted it to create a series
of Antarctic ice paintings,
paintings made in Antarctica
with Antarctica and about Antarctica.
But they weren't just about Antarctica.
They were about where
Antarctica was going.
I returned to Miami
transformed by that experience
and pivoted my art practice to one
where for 15 years now
I’ve been trying to ask,
how do we best engage the public
around climate issues?
Just a few years ago,
I worked with the village of Pinecrest
to develop a socially engaged art project
that would make sea level rise
impossible to ignore.
We called it The Underwater
Homeowners Association.
Let that sink in for a second.
(Laughter)
We used those Antarctic ice paintings
as the backdrop for yard signs
that would map the elevation
of people's homes.
People use an app to find out how many
feet above sea level their homes are.
And then they would either paint
that number on a yard sign
or take home a pre-made one
and they would place it
in their front yards.
Now, you can imagine, when your neighbor
from across the street asks you
what that number eight
in front of your house means,
it's a perfect opportunity
for you to tell them
that they too live
at eight feet above the sea.
And it is in their interest,
in their personal and financial interest,
to understand the consequences
of a warming planet.
The strangeness or weirdness
of these signs --
remember, these aren't political signs
or "home for sale" signs,
these are elevation markers --
is a key component
to a socially engaged project
that makes random people stop
long enough to ask,
"What is this about?"
And it is in that way
that many of my neighbors realized
that although they lived
farther inland from the ocean,
they weren't necessarily
less vulnerable to the rising seas.
You see, in Miami, elevation
generally increases as you move inland
until you hit this ridge
and then it starts dropping
as you approach the Florida Everglades,
the River of Grass,
or what I call Miami's second coastline.
As these yard signs were popping up --
house by house, block by block --
I worked with schools to paint
four street intersections
with their respective elevations.
We call that road Elevation Drive
because it showcased
the elevation of a neighborhood,
rising as you drove inland
and then dropping after you crossed
that barely noticeable ridge.
And as if being flanked by bodies of water
on both sides wasn't enough,
Miami has a third coastline.
It's the water beneath
our feet in the aquifer.
This is where saltwater intrusion
is presently threatening
our drinking water.
And it is the reason why,
when it comes to sea level rise,
dams are not a solution for Miami.
You see, my city is built
on porous limestone rock,
and the water will just
come up through it.
Now, as information about this,
about our project, started getting out,
all hell broke loose.
People started calling the mayor's office,
"What are you doing?
How are you supporting a project
that's going to inherently diminish
our property values?"
And the realtors were aghast.
"How are we going to make sales
in the neighborhood?"
This backlash,
this desire to hide a number
that's in every single one
of our flood insurance documents
made the city officials actually
reconsider the support for the project.
But by then it was too late.
The project had broad community support.
Hundreds of signs
were all over the neighborhood.
People wanted to do something.
So, we convened monthly
Underwater Homeowners Association meetings
where people came together
and they learned from relevant scientists
and experts and practitioners
and ultimately began planning for a future
with faulty septic tanks
and risky real estate
and water that would rise,
but unlike a hurricane storm surge,
will not recede.
I want to emphasize
what I'm talking about here.
I'm talking about social practice,
about socially engaged art.
The objects are important --
the yard signs, the street murals --
but the art is the process.
The art lives in the interaction,
in the community coming together
to plan to strategize.
It is in this way
that socially engaged art
provides a mechanism
that brings different people together
around a shared challenge.
And importantly,
it generates a sense
of agency, of responsibility.
I first started working with my neighbors
on environmental issues
when I witnessed a destruction of wetlands
on a drive down to the Florida Keys.
Miles upon miles of mangroves
were being bulldozed
to make space for a wider road.
And I imagined someone
driving down that road in the future
being clueless about the ecosystem
that once thrived there.
Just like many of us today
are oblivious to the nature
we've already destroyed.
So I used eco art.
I brought my neighbors,
my South Floridians,
on walks through majestic
mangrove forests.
There we were, knee deep in water,
crawling through mangrove roots.
And I would explain that these trees
sequester carbon from the atmosphere.
They support biodiversity,
they protect us from storm surges.
We collected mangrove
propagules, seedlings,
that we would then give
to store owners on Lincoln Road,
the busiest shopping area in Miami Beach.
We asked those store owners
to grow those mangroves
as vertical nurseries
right there inside their stores.
Our volunteers put the seedlings
in disposable cups
and hung them on the merchant
windows as installations
that reference the city grid
that displaced the mangroves
on that very barrier island.
When the people walk by that store,
it's really unexpected to see
a bunch of mangroves in a window.
So they ask a store owner,
"What is this about?"
The owner says, "These mangroves
are reclaiming their island.
Mangrove seedlings used to hang
on this very location, on trees,
before all of this concrete was poured."
Well, when the installations came down
after the seedlings were germinated,
we planted them.
Twenty-five acres of them
on Biscayne Bay.
But more importantly,
we inspired thousands of South Floridians
to become environmental stewards,
to care for the environment.
We did this in partnership with dozens
of schools, museums and libraries.
And it wasn't just about creating
ecosystems above and below the water line.
It was about developing
a cadre of eco emissaries,
of creative problem solvers.
Of Miamians, driven by empathy
and love of community.
Art did that. Art has that power.
Art has the power to break down
barriers and bridge divides.
Art can help us see things
in different ways.
When you look at one of those yard signs
with a number on it and ask,
“What is this about?” --
that's the moment when the seed
of awareness is planted in you.
We've piqued your curiosity.
When you're engaged in an eco art project
and begin caring for mangroves,
walking in that forest, collecting them,
sharing, talking about them,
installing them and then planting them,
you begin to develop a personal
connection with nature.
Finding ways to provoke
that moment of inquiry
and importantly,
creating pathways for further action,
that's what socially engaged art does.
And it is my hope that all of us,
across all sectors,
use the power of art.
That universal language, the power of art,
to engage our communities.
So that individuals can tap
into their own creativity
and work with others
in finding innovative approaches
to build a more just, a more loving
and a more beautiful world.
Thank you.
(Applause)